moving on from freezing fractals to
frozen music no not the music from
frozen but the music from frozen water
we're on the icy surface of Lake Baikal
in Siberia with Russian musicians italia
ethan tatiana and anna it was really
amazing the range of the different
musical notes and the different sounds
they were able to get just by using what
was right there on the frozen lake
surface what you want is a material that
when struck is gonna deform and vibrate
in physics we quantify how easy it is to
the formal material by young's modulus
and it turns out that ice is a
surprisingly good material to use to
construct the musical instrument
interesting but how do you make music
with it when you look at musical
instruments there are different
materials that you strike in order to
make sound you have drum heads you have
xylophones that can have a metal surface
that you strike or a wooden surface that
you strike in the marimba the young's
modulus of ice is quite similar to the
one of wood this means that you can
actually play ice very much like you
play any other wooden instrument they
get a whole range of pitches by taking
advantage of the properties of ice like
the different shapes and the different
elastic properties of it cool music but
be careful
you never know when you're walking on
thin ice